meine sachen die du und im inventar
eingeblendet ist alle weg dass ich dann
ernst
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute mit einer
challenge und zwar die lokal sagt
challenge von wales luca luka spik spaß
okay dann haben uns zu weit auch geklärt
und luca sagt heißt lukat drei mal in
dieser runde jumping die möglichkeit
mich dazu zu zwingen das zu machen was
er sagt das einzige was ausgeschlossen
ist sind so sachen wie schließt
minecraft oder kraft oder verlasst die
runde oder 100 oder sowas wie keine
ahnung
ja genau das ist sich brink oder schlag
den mitbewohner zusammen so was machen
wir nicht heute machen heute nicht also
wir machen im video
so funktioniert das
du musst deine drei wünsche oder deine 3
luca sagt morgens gut verwalten was ist
los in diesen dingen alter mit dingen
minecraft geöffnet und jetzt dachte mir
ich kann also kannst jetzt gar nicht
jetzt macht ihr die wahl schon mal
gedanken wie du deine drei wünsche
einsetzen will ist quasi wie sie sind ja
da muss mir sagen wie schon am springen
gerade oder ja schon längst egal ob
schon 2003 also überlegst dir keiner
leisten
ok ja ich muss ja wirklich weit du
willst
ich bin jetzt bei modul 5 würde ich mal
sagen bist du erst dann
ich würde mal sagen ja meine erste sache
ist geht so weit zurück dass du
vorletzter bist ja doch schon okay ich
kann folgen gar nicht zurückgehen weil
ich so weit runter gefallen wenn dann
warte ich hier einfach okay die schaffen
das niemals mann ich bin mein block 170
und die der vorletzte ist der block 15
der kfk kommt nicht weiter sagen ich hab
noch 15 sekunden
okay okay leute ich hab hier übrigens
eine spange in der hand und ich sitzt
tatsächlich in meiner regenjacke uppsala
viel zu lange gewartet am computer ich
sitze in regenjacke am computer leute
trage nicht warum
einfach ein paar arma 2 die dir noch
eine jacke an ernst aber ich hab die hat
in pulli und jacke ich hab nur so eine
richtig dicke winterjacke mit pelzkragen
ja eine jacke soll ich dann die dicke
erzieherin ja oben drüber
wie das ausgeht aber erstmal den kragen
hoch klassen so viel zeit muss sein
leute ich bin wieder da die junge echte
jetzt muss ich ihnen dem scheiß hier
spielen fühle sie aber eigentlich ganz
angenehm anja kühl die backen wollen
aber irgendwas sagt mir dass sie gleich
warm werden wird die kranichlinie ist
bis jetzt mit jumping wie lange dauert
die runde noch module sechs die ohne
dauert noch dreieinhalb minuten kannst
es dir du kannst natürlich jetzt schon
drauf raushauen dann kann ich aber die
restliche ohne unbeschwert spielen oder
du war deshalb bis zum selfmade dann
noch einen drauf zu machen oder nicht
oder einfach unendlich viele
die dritte sache da habe ich irgendwas
sagen irgendwas ja irgendwas sagen also
halt nichts was irgendwie einschließen
würde dass ich mich selbst umbringen
oder so was halt die dritte sache ich
hätte gerne noch mal zwei sachen den
allgemeinen geschäftsbedingungen der
dschinn dschinn gewerkschaft hat immer
festgelegt jetzt aber hier sozusagen
eins zwei drei
okay ich bin beim modul acht mittendrin
da darf ich
nein nicht unter gefallen wusste
neugeburt wahrscheinlichkeit jetzt auch
das dritte ding verzichten
auch das dritte ding verzichten keine
ahnung mir fällt kein vergleich ein
überleg es dir gut das ist ein letzter
wunsch weiter zum leben in der aufnahme
meiner wünsche aus die können wir schon
mal für diese sinnvolle beiträge das ist
wirklich super und ich mit so gerne
geschenke eröffnet
du bist noch jung ich bin mein gott so
am spieler alten platz zwei und der
abstand auf den ersten schrumpft pumpe
war wieder eine noble
okay der mensch fängt an das fängt ja
liebe hört sich an wie sonne
halbfettmargarine was war das für der
aussage ich so das match ging an luca
soll ja ich finger über das doppel sagen
hallo das ist gehört vielleicht
wichtiger freundeslisten freunde von mir
kommen in zehn minuten und ich bin hier
mit seppl in unterhose und dem auto
sitzt das ging so als wenn wir neben
deinen unterstützen
ich kann meinem schrank moment
drogenring gehört das jetzt nicht mehr
zwischen will wollte was war nochmal aus
ist okay du bist ein bett matches klar
was ist los mit diesem wesen sachen die
du und im inventar eingeblendet die ist
alles weg das ist nicht dein ernst das
ist nicht dein ernst sein
das ist mein ernst macht das junge das
ist alles was ich habe
ich habe einstein stadt geschossen haben
bogen weggeschmissen äpfel cookies
rüstung
ich habe mich meine waffe bickel gegner
geht nun ich habe kein ich hab kein
schwert mehr super luca ich habe einfach
kein einziges schwert die andere
aufgaben wahr den weihnachtsmann
umbringen könnte sagt niemanden
umbringen
ich könnte mir raus nehmen
ok ich könnte mit der hand ob das klappt
ob bitte wie er hat auf mich durchzieht
auch kommen wird ist die ganzen premium
user gehen halt nur auf mich man warte
warte warte ich muss in frage ich muss
irgendwie später bekommen hast du ein
schwert nächster wunsch dass keine leute
fragen bitte du hast kein trost dass
kein wunsch mehr auf zu atmen
jetzt müsste man ja bin ich ich habe mir
die mauther sagt gespielt hat ich muss
kurz anderen channell geht nicht lange
das schwerste in geld ok damit
verständnis sich gleich dazu bestimmt
vielleicht eher wie heißt noch mal ein
game
gerade weil erinnerst du dich noch ich
frage kommst du selbst nicht wenn er
nicht sagen
der eckige konturen bekommen
lukas einfach ganz heiß und ich hätte
überhaupt doch endlich nein nicht ich
bin so weibel menschen verborgen oder
die nudeln
da kannst du auch pastor morgen nudeln
reis ok damit habe ich einfach mal ganz
ruhig weg klatscht import einfach bei
einer brücke ab dass peter aufhören er
macht das hallo weihnachtsmann umbringen
bitte wer zu nudeln kaufen sollen ja
kind auf dem kopf da man nun mal
weihnachtsmann so die runde noch
gewonnen
sehr schön trotz dieser erbarmungslosen
challenge und lud hamid gepackt leute
darf ich das letzte wort haben
nein flirtet bei mir auch das letzte
wort
b